welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is the breakdown of the
falcon in the winter soldier episode 1
falcon lets cap shield go to captain
locker room talk and the winter soldier
gets therapy
in extreme close up i'm going to break
down this episode shot by shot for all
the hidden details layers of meaning
occasionally far-reaching theories for
what is really going on in this series
here we go we open on sam wilson ironing
a dark suit as we hear
how does it feel like it's someone
else's
it isn't words quoted from avengers end
game the moment old man cap handed off
his shield to sam
how does it feel like it's someone
else's
it isn't but the tone of this opening
scene makes it seem like we're headed to
old cap's funeral
and in a way the ceremony sam goes to is
a kind of funeral but for cap's shield
which sam does bury here first in the
metaphorical coffin of this art case
that steve kept it in
which at the time was a nod to his
sketching hobby that he was always doing
on the side and then eventually to its
resting place tomb
of cap's smithsonian exhibit the shield
being a symbol for steve rogers getting
unearthed disrespectfully in the final
scene is a big reason why sam feels so
upset by it not just indiana jones
saying that belongs to a museum but
someone feeling like their buddy's
corpse was dragged out weakened at
style and back in that cn adventures end
game the uplifting music at the time
made sam feel hopeful honored ready in
that moment
but now the exchange removed from that
makes sam come off as doubtful
overwhelmed burdened this
legacy is the core theme of this series
what happens when the torch that you're
passed is not a torch you ever wanted to
bear but rather a flame that you feel is
best left to die
down naturally should also point out
that this shield is technically a
new shield remember cap's historic
shield was broken and destroyed by
thanos during the battle of earth this
one is a new design with new notches and
engravings if you look closely
where did it come from well cap stayed
in the 1940s with peggy carter and
according to the endgame directors he
lived out his life in an alternate
branch history another timeline that
unfolded off-screen so this redesigned
shield could have all kinds of secrets
that old cap left for sam specifically
including many of us have theorized it
could be composed not a vibranium this
time but the original substance that it
was in the comics
proto-adamantium in a mission sam
rescued captain vassant from a criminal
organization called
laf led by georges battrock returning
from captain america the winter soldier
on the ground sam's contact is
first lieutenant juan torres a name from
the marvel comics he's the guy who takes
on the falcon mantle briefly when sam
takes on the cat mantle so in the comics
tori's got his bird powers after being
experimented on by a guy named dr
carl malus aka the power broker malice
is a recurring marvel villain in the
comics he's tied with jessica drew
spider-woman
and lamar hoskins battle star who could
be clay bennett's character in the
series
power broker could be behind a lot of
this and if you're looking closely in
the episode's closing credits there was
a warning saying
power broker is watching sam dives into
action off the plane
just like tony stark's entrance in iron
man 2 and actually throughout this
battle his close-ups kind of parallel
the hud view framing used for iron man
and war machine
great action here sam uses his thrusters
to ram a dude's head into the crate
louie the pilot gets a classic
street bullet hit the driver oh no
except this time he's giving a love tap
there's a moment where a batroc thumps
his chest and then sam responds by
extending his wings it's such a great
macho aggression dancer doing like a
simeon chest
thump and then an avian feather puff now
you remember sam's drone
red wing named after his bird companion
red wing but now the drone responds to
sam's voice commands
red wing get him off our hand yeah red
wing totally just arch you detude
with a bird-like whistle very nice but
then after the battle sanatorius have
this moment you could try to reroute
that together would you not
oh i've been working with the air force
for six months now
every time ops touches him he gets all
glitchy hmm okay so first off six months
telling us this takes place six months
after end game about five months after
the west view anomaly of wanavision
setting this around april 2024 which
would be about two months before
spider-man far from home but more
importantly
sam's testy response now you could read
this as a sign that tories as a
potential successor to sam and the
falcon title
is ready to take over red wing or this
could be
sam suspecting that the military has
been sabotaging his tech before
missions think about it what was this
mission sam was given hardly
any backup on this dangerous hush-hush
operation and then surprise surprise the
hijacking was already in progress
it's all to save some captain before
they get into libyan airspace
why it's also suspect that batroc is
involved because remember
that dude was actually paid by nick fury
to capture the lemurian star
there's a lot of double crossing going
on in winter soldier which feels like is
the case in this show i'm very excited
batroc led a whole sneaky military
operation that specifically kept
an avenger in the blind from his own
government look i'm just saying i would
not be surprised if in the show sam is
being set up to fail
so that the government could replace him
with torah's falcon just like they have
their own poster boy to replace
cap torres also suspiciously live
streams everything
and he takes a mental note when he hears
sam speaking to arabic he knows arabic
wait can you say that again
and during this story this app shows an
ar symbol of the flag smashers
basically they think that the world is
better during the blip
trust me it wasn't trust me every time
something gets better for one group
it gets worse for another aha sam gives
his take on inequality which does come
back later this episode and then torrey
says this about the flag smashers
essentially these people they want a
world that's
unified without borders so you can see
why a lot of people are into that so the
flag smashers get their name from flag
smasher carl morgenthau
a cat villain who has a similar
philosophy aaron kellyman is playing a
character named
carly morgenthau probably the actual
leader of this group and then tories
asks what happened to
cap i do got to ask you though because
like online there's just been a lot of
a lot of stuff about steve actually some
people they think that
he's in a secret base on the moon
wow i can assure you those people you
don't have to take seriously i don't
have to
take the online theorist seriously okay
ouch i get it but i bring it up because
torres is
eager to know where cap is so
if old cap is not dead where is he well
the moon's not that crazy of an answer
in the mcu because there are avengers
currently in space
nick fury is aboard a scroll space
station alongside it sounds like monica
rambo now after that one division
post-credits scene i'm just saying this
show did not have to bring up this
mystery
at all so since it did in the opening
episode i think we can expect some kind
of answer
then moving on boom you're looking for
roadie he attends sam's shield handing
off ceremony
we need new heroes
one suited for the times we're in sam
i'm not that old
we see some relics from cap's first film
his motorcycle headlines about bombers
hitting hydra targets the howling
commandos uniform
steve's 4f denial form that captain
america number one cover where hitler
gets punched which they restate during
that uso tour sequence but this exhibit
has been updated with new mcu history
we see plaques reading bucky barnes
friend and brother killed in action and
then
winter soldier from friend to foe then a
threat from within
hydra the segovia chords a team divided
also the illuminated walls show symbols
of the eagle from the sagovian flag
the shield logo in the hydra logo then
bucky's civil war plaque reads captain
america himself led this effort to bring
barnes to justice and later aided in the
escape from custody having been
convinced of his innocence steve's
loyalty to his old brain coupled with
his refusal to sign the sokovia accords
led to the disillusion of the avengers
and drove the captain into hiding with
other like-minded avengers including
natasha romanov wanda maximoff and sam
wilson the current whereabouts of barnes
remains unknown
having been labeled a fugitive following
his escape from custody then we get an
infinity war plaque
showing ebony moss q ship hovering over
new york city reading out of hiding new
york under attack
something something former avengers
including national roman emwant of
maximuff and sam wilson was forced to
operate off the grid and live a new life
as fugitives after aiding and abetting
accused bonds
with some ties to shield and the
intelligence community still intact the
team was forced to aid in the protection
of earth and its citizens after two
years of operating outside the law a new
threat from above brought steve rogers
and his team out of hiding to once again
joined the fight
new york was under attack and much like
the events of 2012 that led to the
forming of the avengers the threat was
from another world
while the casualties destruction and
impact of this event seem to have much
less of an impression as a whole
it wasn't until short time later that
the true effect of the damage was
suffered
referring to the you know we all
remember and then we see a nice long
list
of names from the vanished mt actually
helped me go through this and a lot of
these are real-life marvel studios
employees we got victoria alonso
executive producer for the show
derek colstad a writer for the series
jack lazzaro a key makeup artist frank
amoroso or construction pa for infinity
war kelsey liu production and
development manager
phil langone a storyboard artist for
homecoming and far from home sean
windish a special effects for many
marvel titles denise woodguard a dailies
producer
ben woodworth marvel special effects
artist noah wellner marvel
transportation courtney young the
dialect coach her name actually appeared
in the one of vision credits
carolyn yovotich an assets coordinator
kelly zack makeup artist lionel
zappian a special effects tech chuck
zlatnick a marvel photographer
kaylin littleton christopher lucas vfx
artist and richard lupton vfx artist
there's probably more names that are
people here but then we see the board
for the blip followed by a plaque
reading a final mission the vanishing
resulted in the disappearance of half of
all life in the universe captain america
was unable to overcome the loss
after five years of drifting captain
america and the remaining avengers were
able to regroup with a new plan to under
the damage inflicted by the mad titan
known as thanos
this time steve rogers and his team were
successful and able to save those that
had vanished but with some personal loss
with the death of tony stark steve
rogers honored his friend by finally
laying down his shield
enjoying the things he had fought so
hard to protect and with this exhibit we
honor the life and legacy of steve
rogers captain america soldier hero now
notice how this doesn't mention what cap
did in the time heist either in the main
time heist or the final trip he takes to
return the stone so
to the rest of the world it's still a
mystery where old cap is and the kids at
midtown high thought he was just dead or
gone
then rudy says world's a crazy place
right now
people are well nobody's stable
allies are now enemies alliances are all
torn apart the world's broken
yeah the world is still a mess six
months later and these words kind of
echo fury's caution at the top of
captain america winter soldier
trust no one even the people you thought
were allies they're talking to you sam
you're being set up buddy and then this
final shot sam's reflection is
superimposed on the shield paralleling
that shot of steve in the first
cap film framing also scene of doctor
strange and into the spider-verse a hero
struggling to see himself fitting in
that suit
and of course this shield is on sam's
left bucky he experiences a nightmare of
a memory of a past winter soldier
mission i love how the opening shot of
this hotel you can see his shadow
creeping across the ceiling creepy
and this music should also sound
familiar
[Music]
they brought back henry jackman composer
of winter soldier and created
this chilling distorted cry for bucky by
himself screaming into a drum
to evoke bucky's scream as he fell into
hydra's clutches
bucky delivers the kill with hell hydra
if bucky gave this via conveyors to
every kill imagine howard stark and
maria stark hearing hill hydra in their
final moments god bucky wakes from this
nightmare sleeping on the floor
reminding us of sam and steve's chat
before
it's your bed right what's that
your bed it's too soft when i was over
there i sleep on the ground use rock for
pillows like a caveman
now i'm home lying in my bed and it's
like lying on a marshmallow
i feel like i'm going to sink right to
the floor director cary skoglin frames
bucky's therapy oddly
first in front of this forest mural
springtime the winter soldier melting
away into spring but then these
uncomfortable extreme close-ups angled
downward this is to convey the
claustrophobic anxiety bucky feels in
this moment getting interrogated like
that
bucky talked about how he made amends
with the corrupt senator atwood former
hydra member and he claims to have
followed the three rules given
by the therapist don't do anything legal
don't hurt anyone and repeat the mantra
i'm no longer the winner soldier i'm
james bucky barnes and you're
part of my efforts to make amends
also face off reigns not food you think
about a bucky actually
only follow the third rule but to be
fair that was probably the hardest one
of the three for him to do so
and then he crosses atwood off his list
listing in a small notebook like this is
another cat parallel cap listed new
things to learn bucky lists old things
to fix now among these names
is a rostov maybe for andre rostov aka
the red barbarian a soviet general and
arms dealer in the comics he wardened a
gulag where bucky was imprisoned and
then later was killed in the bahamas
during a sale of the zephyr codes
assumed to be a winter soldier hit
pw hauser is the name of the actor who
co-starred alongside sebastian stan and
i tanya
a kendrick sin could refer to how
hendrickson a soldier who got the venom
symbiote before flash in later marvel
comics
and kuznatov could be a reference to the
name of the soviet scientist who created
the udarnic android and then of course
h zemo for helmutz zemo from civil war
who is returning in the series as if he
had a no show
but he did frame bucky and get the
avengers all broken up trailer voted
shows bucky coming face to face with
zemo
cannot wait for that conversation then
there's el kaminsky could be for lim
kaminsky comics writer but what i love
most about this shot is that in the very
first frame of it you can see a small
glimpse of the next page
where at the top of that why nakajima
yori nakajima the father of the
bystander bucky murdered in the hotel
literally the next name on bucky's list
and this whole list is a reminder of
bucky's heartbreaking response to tony
in civil war
do you even remember them i remember all
of them
but before we continue thank you to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero
sugars and zero artificial flavors each
16 ounce can contains
300 milligrams of caffeine super
creatine coq10 and bcaas
i am sipping on rainbow unicorn not like
those thundercloud unicorns the unicorns
that make you feel happy when you sip
them it's just sweet and light like
you're on the back of a unicorn
leaping over a more depressed unicorn i
honestly rely on bangs when i'm shooting
those early morning after shows
and i don't want my eyes to look like
i'm half asleep when i'm trying to break
down these easter eggs i need my mind to
be alert
check out bang on instagram you can get
ten percent off your order at dang
energy.com when you use the code new
rockstars 10.
rainbow there you can buy a variety pack
of bang energy or grab a 12 pack of
citrus twist
bankster berry the new delish strawberry
kiss
use my code new rockstars 10 and receive
off your bang energy order that's code
new rockstars 10 for
10 off bucky gets lunch with mr nakajima
whom he adorably relates with as a
fellow elderly man
down to reading the obituaries from the
newspaper take a look
nobody made it past 90 this week
so young such a shame and then you
already sees the mochi and remembers his
son
now bucky seems to understand yuri's
japanese kind of like sam he's
surprisingly multilingual though i guess
bucky was an international assassin
he was also able to speak romanian and
bucharest now yuri's sadness here
triggers bucky's winter soldier past
again you can tell by this music sting
ah but it softens right as bucky blinks
see only by blinking
can bucky quiet the screen giving
context to that trailer clip where he's
mocked for never blinking
just blank sweet jesus i mean how old
are you it's because he never forgets
sam visits his family in louisiana his
two nephews and his sister sarah
uncle sam what's up
that's right uncle sam
yeah i love how sarah paint sam as a us
military propaganda tool despite sam
turning down that legacy
and when it comes to this whole boat
stuff you wish vision was here he could
totally help sam make this boat
profitable
all you have to do is dismantle this
vessel plank by plank and build a second
ship enthusiast out of it that they
could write off as a business expense
on a date with leah the sushi server
bucky gets into a
cat fight
and then some awkward small talk what
are you doing i'm reading your mind
please don't yeah bucky is warning you
don't wanna know what's going on in my
mind but also
hey lady i spent decades with people
controlling my mind stay out of it
meanwhile torres flash mobs with the
flag smashers who robbed this swiss bank
switzerland of course is the home
country of arnhem zola
zola train but really swiss banks have
the reputation of looking the other way
for criminal enterprises so i'm
wondering if the flag smashers could be
ripping off a crime lord here maybe
someone headquartered madrapore we'll
see
sam and sarah are denied a bank loan
from the douchiest banker
how do you guys make a living i mean
your financials are all over the place
is there some kind of fun for heroes or
did stark pay you when he was around
my condolences by the way the avengers
income and expenses has been a recurring
question for the mcu
in the comics it's reported that they
make six-figure salaries via government
contracts but it was never really clear
how team cap runaways got by for two
years on the run
my guess was that t'challa could have
hooked them up with funding given steve
and t'challa's arrangement after civil
war
sam refuses to give up and sell the
family boat we're not selling our
family's legacy
this parallels sam's feelings about cap
shield sam got a rude awakening about
how your rightful legacy
can be unfairly taken from you you can't
just preserve these things in stone for
whenever he wants to go home to visit
them
legacy is something you have to work and
fight to preserve he has to do it with
the wilson family boat he's got to do it
with the shield sammy torres disgust the
flag smashers
anything else happen outside the video
no man my my face was in the dirt before
i knew what was happening
why what are you thinking nothing
wait you don't think you could be uh
i'll circle back to you
let's keep this between me and you uh
what i feel like we're back with west
view herb here she came here because
we're all what wait did we ever find out
we're all
trapped in want to sex reality but at
this particular moment being
additionally puppeted by agatha and
agatha is only pretending to be nervous
here i'm still trying to unpack all the
layers of that
he may have been about to say that the
plague smashers super strength as a
result of
super soldier serum since we know from
the winter soldier program that other
batches of serum were out there
and back in phase one thaddeus ross was
trying to reboot cap's super soldier
program which led to hulk and
abomination that might also explain that
flag smashers disaffected political
views like with worldwide anarchy
there's no government that can weaponize
you
and this could support the theory that
ross has a secret replacement avengers
team called the thunderbolts i have also
made the case for
mutants like perhaps the events of end
game finally activated the mutant gene
and certain members of the population
or if this power broker malice is behind
this
these could be enhanced humans from his
experiments now the press conference
plays on w-h-i-h
the mcu news service we saw that in
wanovision and then they introduced the
new captain america
john walker played by wyatt russell now
in comics john walker goes by super
patriot aka u.s
agent he's a wrestler turned vigilante
aiming to take over the cap mantle he's
kind of a jerk
now this same government official who
introduced him previously told sam that
handing in the shield was the right
thing to do
obviously this guy in the whole
government never intended to keep it in
the museum which feeds my suspicion that
the government is setting up sam to fail
they are not on his side and then walker
freaking winks
at us a coy little fu to sam and
something we learned from mag of the
harkness not a trustworthy sign at all
getting some major homeland revives here
but more importantly on his hip is a
gun now cap used a gun in world war ii
it was a world war
but he didn't really use one in the
modern era his shield was his primary
weapon so the fact that walker has a gun
right now tells us that he and his
handlers really want to revert cap to a
propaganda tool that he was in the 40s
but more worrisome that they do not
appreciate the true worth of this shield
in his hands now the end credits
actually reveal a lot of clues in the
form of this graffiti and wall art old
uncle sam and cat propaganda posters
a beastly figure with chinese lettering
maybe assigned to that bronze monkey
club in madrapore
an illuminati eye maybe a nod to the cap
related conspiracy theories out there
graffiti from the flag smashers one
world people there's a headline saying
shadow group pulls off weapons heists
which could refer to the flag smashers
and then a search log for subject 02656
and then right next to this subject form
is the face of carl lumley who
was rumored to be in this cast a lot of
us believe that he could be playing
isaiah bradley
the original black cap whose history was
kind of erased this legacy seems to be
something that's gonna be very important
sam going forward how do you reconcile
these two things
also we see another headline related to
this that says all information regarding
the enhanced humans act has been
reported to be classified by
major donovan of special unit something
so yeah maybe there was some secret
government program to enhance humans
that we haven't been told about yet this
could be what thaddeus ross was working
on someone who who knows
he was secretary of state before he
might be president ross now he could be
the president who issued that part in
and selected this new replacement cap
maybe he had some thunderbolts-esque
enhancement program
involving the power broker we also see
the text agent 13 that's referencing
sharon carter then we see public law 107
the nation is called upon to recognize
the patriotism of fellow citizens from
all ethnic racial and religious
this reference to government code that
says that the military's not allowed
to discriminate based off of any of
these things something that could also
be related to the history of black cap
then a headline masked man plagues
downtown prague which could be
referenced in zemo or
taskmaster from the black widow film who
seems like a masked figure who could be
terrorized in these eastern european
cities then conditions of release you
must appear in court when order he must
obey all court orders you must notify 24
hours before moving this seems to be the
conditions of bucky's pardon or maybe
the conditions of zemo's release
then we see the date december 16th 1991
that's a date bucky killed howard stark
and maria stark also there's later a
mission report from hydra where it
mentions long island new york where this
took place then a postcard from madrid
but then the most interesting one to me
something that looks like a bullet
casing containing a blue fluid
maybe darts containing super soldier
serum the text before the title comes up
where do we go now that they're gone
where do we go now they're gone of
course it was with a text on the poster
in steve rogers support group and end
game and then outlines of people with
half of them filled in black maybe for
half of the vanished persons
and then again power broker is watching
then something that says district of
columbia support group check-in that's
sam's veterans group that he does
counseling with then a headline that
says senator atwood pushes for perimeter
border enforcement so maybe the senator
that bucky got arrested was pushing for
some border enforcement there then this
interesting thing article 33 no
contracting state shall expel or return
a refugee in any manner whatsoever
this actually comes from the u.n refugee
agency a condition that was published in
informing what participating nation
states should do with refugees
maybe a little political statement from
the show right here something that might
play an important role in the show maybe
some of these flag smashers were
rejected refugees and then some text
that says must reveal their legal names
and true identities to the united
nations i assume
this is from the sokovia accords we get
a us army poster for john walker
cap is back but then someone tagged on
him manufactured hero
so even they know this guy is a phony
propaganda tool
and then missing posters for loved ones
lost in the blip paper peeling back to
show the winter soldier activation code
words and then the purple mask of zemo
hopefully someone we will see next
episode and then a quick flashing of
text if you look closely reading
enhanced individuals won't save us quite
an interesting slogan who wrote this
where is it coming from maybe some
government propaganda they don't want us
to trust avengers anymore
trust our new team of homegrown heroes
and these words inspired our merch
partners for our new latest obsession
shirt you can get that at
newrockstarsmerch.com whenever you do
you'll get the added option to write in
a custom shout out that will appear on
screen during our inside marvel falcon
winter soldier after shows and folks a
big channel announcement that i'm very
nervous about
this sunday two days from now we will be
launching the first episode of a new
series from the mind to philip molina
called fitness origins
philip roped tommy and me into a 12-week
fitness challenge
inspired by the heroes of the marvel
cinematic universe philip's challenges
are crazy
and a bit terrifying i honestly have no
idea what's going on with the show but i
can promise you
you will get to see a very fragile side
of me giving many of you hate watching
these videos plenty of clips to drag my
very tired loaded corpse on twitter
so follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for everything marvel
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you